dimanche dernier une compétition de
canicross était censée se dérouler mais
l'activité sportive a viré au drame ces
chiens empoisonnés à l'occasion du
championnat de France de canicross dans
le Gard pour rappel le canicross est une
discipline originale qui fait courir des
chiens avec leur maître mais très vite
alors qu'il devait passer une journée
agréable une nouvelle se répand parmi
les participants à une annonce retentit
pour les alerter le terrain a été miné
par des personnes très insuffisantes
avec des boulettes de viande
empoisonnées au total trois chiens sont
retrouvés morts quelques minutes après
avoir ingéré ce poison le choc et
l'émotion immédiatement gagné
participant et organisateurs
j'arrive pas à voir comment on peut
faire ça
scandale des chiens empoisonné lors d'un
concours canin la colère de
l'organisateur ce soir dans TPMP
si vous nous rejoignez cette histoire
est folle scandale des chiens
empoisonnés lors d'un concours canin
Sébastien Simon directeur technique
fédéral de la fsls la Fédération des
Sports et Loisirs canin quatre chiens se
sont retrouvés intoxiqué avant le départ
de la course dimanche matin c'est
incroyable alors on a moi j'ai suivi
cette affaire on vient nous dire ce que
vous en pensez mais comment ça s'est
passé en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que le ce week-end c'était les
championnats de France de la fslc le
samedi et il y avait la première manche
qui a eu lieu donc c'est très bien passé
en fait dans la nuit du samedi au
dimanche il y a eu des boulettes de
viande avec du poison dedans qui ont été
parsemés sur le sur le sur les parkings
une première alerte en fait a été donnée
quand je suis premier chien est tombé et
en fait 5 6 minutes après il y a eu deux
autres chiens qui ont eu les mêmes
symptômes on a l'équipe vétérinaire qui
intervenu vraiment très rapidement pour
prendre en charge justement c'est ces
chiens et qui ont été après très
rapidement vous voyez
chez les vétérinaires pour essayer de
faire le nécessaire sauf qu'il était
déjà trop tard donc derrière donc c'est
un acte criminel c'est un acte criminel
c'est tout simplement un fou et un
criminel qui a délibérément mis ses
boulettes sur le parking en fait c'était
sur un parking qui nous permettait de
promener les chiens qui se détendent
avant les courses donc en aucun cas nous
quand on est arrivé le dimanche matin on
se doutait que le qu'on avait vivre une
journée de cauchemars pour nos chiens
c'était déjà arrivé ça ou pas non c'est
jamais arrivé c'est vraiment moi pas
personnel ça fait 10 ans que je fais du
canicross je fais donc plusieurs courses
et c'est vraiment la première fois qu'on
vit à quelque chose comme ça et donc
c'était un vrai traumatisme pour nous et
aujourd'hui en tout cas j'ai une grosse
pensée pour les trois propriétaires des
chiens qui sont effondrés effondré parce
que nos chiens c'est tout simplement nos
ils font partie de notre famille
et donc en aucun cas on aurait pensé en
venant sur un canicross que on aurait
des gens qui repartiraient sans leur
chien malheureusement alors c'était ce
dimanche 12 mars aux alentours de 7h30
du matin avant que le concours débute
trois chiens ont ingéré des boulettes de
viande un produit à limace aurait été
introduit dans ces dernières alors c'est
une suspicion pour l'instant il y a une
enquête qui est en cours l'agenda
pourquoi le produit à Lima c'est ça
c'est en fait c'est vraiment c'est le
dosage qui a été donné en fait qu'on
mais c'est surtout que les vétérinaires
ça a été les premières choses qui par
rapport au ce qui s'est passé sur les
chiens ont détecté mais après
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment une suspicion
puisque l'enquête est toujours ouverte
il y a une analyse qui doit être faite
cette boulette des différents minutes
après les chiens oui c'est ça 15 minutes
après avoir c'est incroyable le taux
hyper violent c'est un produit si c'est
bien ça le carbam mat qui est maintenant
interdit à la vente en France tellement
il est violent et toxique et il y a même
un chien qui est mort aujourd'hui Cyril
le 4e un autre
il a quitté une habitation et comme il
reste des boulettes parce que ils ont
fait un gros effort de ramassage les
gendarmes il en reste il en a ingéré une
et il est mort aujourd'hui le périmètre
est interdit mais visiblement ça a
dépassé et c'est forcément
éliminer des candidats c'est ça que la
question alors exactement ils ont très
vite j'avais très vite écarté la piste
de la concurrence interne c'est à dire à
un concurrent qui voudrait tuer les
autres etc ça vous dites que c'est pas
vous mais si c'est pas ça forcément
c'est quelqu'un qui ne voulait pas de
vous sur le périmètre avant que ce soit
un fou donc qui ça peut être un chasseur
vous pensez alors déjà c'est tout
simplement impossible que ça soit
quelqu'un de la compétition parce que
moi c'est ce que j'ai pensé il y a
beaucoup de gens malheureusement qu'on
pensait ça c'est impossible tout
simplement parce qu'en fait on se
connaît tous d'accord le milieu du
canicross c'est un milieu qui est où on
est tous très proche on se voit
régulièrement pour pas dire presque tous
les weekends sur les différents
canicross qu'on lui en France donc c'est
quelque chose qui est tout simplement
impossible on se connaît tous on est
tous amis et ben il y a des éleveurs
qu'on voit donc une personne qui aurait
fait en fait il aurait tué peut-être le
chien d'un ami mais c'est tout
simplement quelque chose qu'on réfute
vraiment
il y a pas de jalousie en fait on est
vraiment là pour gagner pour gagner avec
ses chiens mais surtout pour s'amuser il
y a pas d'argent aujourd'hui ce qui a
gagné c'est un paquet de croquettes
c'est il y a pas d'argent avec le prix
du
ça commence à devenir une dent et rare
mais aujourd'hui non il y a pas d'argent
qui a un jeu et pour nous c'est tout
simplement impossible que ce soit
quelqu'un du milieu tout à vous disiez
les les
chasseurs aujourd'hui on ne va pas faire
de dire ça peut être les chasseurs ou un
tel ou un tel il y a une enquête on
laisse l'enquête se faire et est-ce
qu'un témoin a été aperçu un individu
malveillant lors du concours pas
d'individus malveillants mais il y a
énormément d'audition il y a 20
gendarmes le laboratoire de Lyon les
enquêteurs venus de Marseille c'est pris
très au sérieux il y a eu des plaintes
vous la mairie mais pour le moment dans
les auditions il y a pas un témoin
direct de la pose de de ces fameuses
boulettes ce qui est compliqué c'est que
nous on fait du sport en fait en plein
air donc déjà on peut pas sécuriser
l'intégralité d'une forêt ce qui est sûr
en tout cas j'en profite pour remercier
la gendarmerie parce qu'ils sont
vraiment intervenus très rapidement ils
ont pris ça très au sérieux comme vous
disiez il y a eu plein de témoignages le
chien les chiens sont morts
non plus c'est en pleine forêt les
voitures qui gênent
en fait pour choisir un site pour un
championnat de France justement on
descend avant sur place beaucoup très
longtemps avant pour pour vérifier le
site voir qu'il y a pas de non plus trop
d'habitation aux alentours tout est
vérifié avant et il y a toujours les
accords des mairies et de la préfecture
donc derrière vraiment tout est fait
dans les règles pour pour des chiens qui
aboient énormément
il y avait des voisins qui des boulettes
dans les jardins parce qu'elle chien qui
aboie trop etc donc je me dis forcément
du bruit on était quand même 550
participants mais maintenant il y a des
habitations la ville était quand même
loin et pas non plus à côté
vous êtes vachement confiant qui sait
pas quelqu'un de du ah oui c'est ça je
crois en fait 550 tout le monde se
connaît tout le monde se connaît
[Musique]
je connais des gens mais si je peux
mettre du poison j'en mets calme-toi
quand même calme-toi
l'organisation n'avait pas reçu de
menaces
aucune menace c'est vraiment pour nous
comme je disais c'est vraiment un
positif sur quelqu'un de chez nous on se
connaît tous c'est en interne il y a
aucun conflit nous c'est vraiment le
plaisir de courir avec nos chiens qui
sont nos chiens de famille comme c'est
des paquets de croquettes à gagner une
médaille il y a pas de il y a rien à
gagner non moi ce qui est vraiment
triste là dedans c'est que je le disais
pardon monsieur mais les probabilités
malgré la gendarmerie de retrouver le
papa sont extrêmement faibles il y a pas
d'ADN sur les boulettes il y a pas eu de
témoin pour le moment ce que j'ai lu il
y a pas de caméra il y avait beaucoup de
gens il y a la proba de retrouver le
débile que j'étais des boulettes elle
est extrêmement faible on lance pas
enfin et c'est ça qui me rend fou c'est
que sauf si c'est un tueur en série qui
recommence ailleurs
les animaux sont souvent et les peines
probable sont extrêmement faibles
c'était 3 ans de prison
des stages de citoyenneté qui servent à
rien moi je me demande de me kiffer ça
qui se lève le matin et se dit tiens je
vais prendre du plaisir à faire des
boulettes empoisonnés pour tuer des
chiens c'est cruel imaginez que ça
arrive avec des enfants ce serait
dramatique c'est ça alors c'est ça la
police s'en occupe mais vu les peines
qu'il en cours ça va être encore bon ben
c'est pas grave il a dit ok qui fera pas
d'aveugle comme on l'a vu hier tu frappe
une vieille dame évidemment mais là pour
vous non mais je trouve que on minimise
encore trop pour les chiens c'est
quelque chose de cruel c'est quelque
chose d'infam et pour moi un canify
comme un homicide c'est extrêmement
grave c'est tout voilà ça c'est vrai
alors aujourd'hui il y a une enquête
forcément les propriétaires des chiens
doivent être députés aujourd'hui c'est
même pas dépité c'est qu'ils sont
dévastés ces trois chiens qui sont venus
enfin de se dire qu'on arrive sur une
course avec son chien qu'on va passer un
super weekend avec son chien avec les
amis la communauté du canicross et on
part sans son chien comment vous avez à
quel moment vous avez vous avez compris
que c'était des il y avait des boulettes
empoisonnées bah en fait moi je suis
arrivé sur site à 6h15 il y avait déjà
le l'organisation qui était là quand on
a commencé à avoir une première alerte
bah les vétos sont intervenus tout de
suite sur les chiens et à partir de là
ils nous ont dit il y a un souci quand
on a vu qu'il y avait des boulettes au
niveau des parkings on a dit il y a un
problème donc là l'organisateur a réagi
très vite l'équipe véto également et les
chiens commencent à se passer ils ont
mangé les boulettes et 15 minutes après
comment en fait tomber c'était
tremblement plus des vomissements donc à
partir de là les vétos ont emmené tout
de suite les chiens au Cabinet
Vétérinaire de la véto qui était sur vos
verres sauf que derrière on a eu le
retour comme quoi les chiens étaient
décédés déjà il en fait ils sont décédés
dans la dans la voiture
donc après même plus rapidement mais une
fois qu'on a su ça en fait le comité de
la Fédération de la fslc l'équipe
vétérinaire et l'organisateur en conseil
réuni on m'a dit on arrête là parce que
ça devient trop dangereux quand vous
disiez il y aurait un enfant qui a
touché ses boulettes qui aurait mis la
main à la bouche en fait ça aurait été
un enfant qui aurait pu mourir il y
avait énormément de chiens donc lors de
la réunion est-ce vous avez une idée de
la quantité de boulettes qui avait été
disposée est-ce que l'idée c'était
l'idée macabre de faire une tuerie de
masse de centaines de chiens parce
qu'avec quelques dizaines de boulettes
j'avais en fait toutes les boules nous
tout ce qu'on a trouvé c'est au niveau
des parkings qui étaient tout en haut en
fait vraiment sur la zone où on pouvait
balader les chiens sur cette zone là on
a trouvé entre une 15 20 boulettes mais
après même si on a ratissé tout ça
pouvait des mini boulettes on sait pas
vraiment ce que ce qui était dans le
voilà c'est parce qu'il y avait dans le
à quoi ça ressemble ou qui pourrait
n'avoir partout
heureusement que la loi était renforcée
quand même parce que maintenant c'est
bon alors j'espère qu'on trouvera les
coupables c'est 50 prisons c'est plus du
tout négligeable et heureusement acte de
cruauté suivi de mort d'un animal
domestique et 75000 euros d'amende donc
effectivement il faut le dire aussi vous
le disiez je sais pas Mathieu se
retrouvera le ou les coupables mais
l'enquête elle est vraiment hyper
efficace pour le moment de les gros
moyens ont été mis pour retrouver le
coupable ça c'est bien tout à fait
et donc c'est pour ça que je remercie
vraiment la gendarmerie parce qu'ils ont
ils sont intervenus très rapidement et
je voudrais en profiter aussi pour
remercier l'équipe vétérinaire parce que
bah ils ont fait un très gros travail et
le choc pour eux était assez dur parce
que ils se sont censés impuissants quand
ils ont vu que bah ça devenait compliqué
pour faire quelque chose et donc je
souhaiterais vraiment les félicités
quelque chose il faut appeler à
gendarmerie de Vauvert pour faire une
déclaration
ils prennent toutes les déclarations qui
peuvent se faire donc aujourd'hui la
l'enquête est en cours de voir qui a
commis ce métier merci